thanks to skillshare for supporting this
episode of journey to the microcosmos
the first 1000 people to click the link
in the description can get a free trial
of skillshare's premium membership
[Music]
you've probably gone through something
like this before you have a loaf of
bread sitting around waiting to be eaten
and you fully intend to eat it you might
even have had the perfect sandwich in
mind but then you go grab some slices
and you notice that someone or something
got to it first
it's the mold the dreaded hairy patches
of black blue green and grey expanding
like a circular lawn
intent on taking over your bread
[Music]
it seems to come out of nowhere but once
it arrives there is no getting rid of it
if you've been following our journey
through the micro cosmos for a while now
you might remember that we talked about
slime molds before so maybe it seems to
you that we have covered mold already
except that when it comes to nature it
turns out that historically humans have
not been so great at naming things which
is not entirely our fault we have for
obvious reasons tended to use similar
names to describe organisms that look
similar to each other and slime molds
kinda resemble bread mold with the way
they both fly around the world as small
spores and the way that they both creep
and spread across surfaces
but this resemblance hides some pretty
big differences for example a slime mold
is a protozoan which means that the
large organism you see is actually a
single-celled eukaryote able to push the
boundaries of its one cell further and
further and further
mold
regular old mold like the kind you see
on bread
are not anything like that they are an
entirely different kingdom in fact
they
are fungi and there are a few fungal
species that are known to make up bread
molds specifically the most common of
which are the multicellular risopus
and cladosporium
as we said fungi are their own kingdom
of life just like protozoans and plants
but while their growth and way of life
might make them sometimes resemble
members of other kingdoms like plants
and protozoans it turns out fungi are
the animal kingdom's closest relations
of course family relations mean nothing
when there's food on the table and fungi
are not like us they can't just go to
the store to pick up a loaf of bread
they can however
travel
flying through the air or swimming
through water as spores
these spores are kind of like seeds
waiting for the right combination of
temperature acidity and moisture to take
root and for some lucky spores bread can
potentially provide those conditions
especially pre-sliced bread which has
all those nutritious nooks and crannies
to grow in
and mold are very good at growing
starting from the spore the fungus
begins to expand in the form of threads
called hyphy the hyphae grow at the tips
they're walls made out of tough but
flexible chitin that allows them to get
creative sometimes the hyphy form
branches of their own and sometimes they
will fuse with one another
the result is a web of hyphy called the
mycelium but the mycelium is not just a
matter of spreading it's a network that
acts as a feeding apparatus the hyphae
will secrete enzymes into the bread
around it breaking down its nutrients so
that the fungus can eat it's basically
just a really large network of mouths
this makes for a frustrating sight when
looking at our despondent gross slices
of bread but when you see a piece of
mold growing and eating away at a piece
of bread you are seeing a loose
approximation of the same processes that
made our world possible
we've seen this before with lichen a
collaboration between fungi and algae
that breaks down rocks into the mineral
components that sustain other forms of
life and fungi can break down
so much more there are even species in
chernobyl eating away at radioactive
material like hot graphite
fungi they could eat the world if they
wanted to
but their path is much more subtle than
their fuzzy appearance might suggest
because fungi don't just tear things
apart they also form relationships
significant essential relationships with
other organisms a plant's roots for
example might become intimately entwined
with a fungi's hyphae forming a bond
that we call mycorrhizae
and as fungi hook themselves up to
different plants they connect the plants
themselves serving as living bridges to
exchange everything from nutrients to
chemical warning messages
so it is tempting when writing about
fungi to treat them as something that
needs to be redeemed after all for many
of us fungi are just the thing that rots
they put an end to our bread our fruits
and our snacks and it's so easy to
redeem them when they clear the world
for us when the bread mold that disgusts
us also famously supplied us with
penicillin an antibiotic that after its
accidental discovery in mold went on to
save countless lives
but fungi however prevalent they may be
are a challenge to pin down
in his book entangled life the
mycologist merlin sheldrake writes
i have tried to find ways to enjoy the
ambiguities that fungi present but it's
not always easy to be comfortable in the
space created by open questions
agoraphobia can set in it's tempting to
hide in small rooms built from quick
answers
i've done my best to hold back
ambiguity is not difficult to find in
nature especially when we're venturing
into the micro cosmos these are
organisms that speak to a world that
long predates us
and in their enduring nature they
suggest a bit of what the world may look
like
after us
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and we'd like to also
say thank you to skillshare for
supporting this video if you're looking
for a more aesthetically pleasing way to
bring fungus into your home you can
check out the sculpt your own mushrooms
course on skillshare host stephanie
kilgast will guide you along as you use
polymer clay to sculpt and then paint
three different kinds of fungus for a
fantastic desktop display
it's a fun project that can be done in a
couple hours and there are no special
skills required so you can start making
your own mushrooms
right now and there are tons of easy to
start classes like this on skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community that offers membership with
meaning with so much to explore
real-world projects to create and the
support of fellow creatives skillshare
empowers you to accomplish real growth
it's curated specifically for learning
meaning there are no ads to distract you
and they're always launching new premium
classes so you can stay focused and
follow wherever your creativity takes
you and an annual subscription to
skillshare is less than ten dollars a
month if you're one of the first 1 000
people to click the link in the
description you can get a free trial of
skillshare's premium membership
the people on the screen right now well
they are our patreon patrons every
single one of them is like a delightful
little fungal spore implanting itself in
the fertile ground of the microcosmos
and then stretching their mycorrhizae
out and secreting digestive enzymes into
our creative brains so that we can
continue to pump out good
microcosmos content if you want to
become one of those delightful spores i
don't know if this is a good pitch or
not regardless you can go to patreon.com
journey2micro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss check out jam
and germs on instagram and if you want
to see more from us there's always a
subscribe button somewhere nearby